hey guys just gonna set you on top of a
suitcase right now i hope you hope you
enjoy it you may notice my my room my
office is a complete disaster i'm gonna
say
that it's because of the earthquake
that's what i'm gonna say i'm gonna
blame it on the los angeles earthquakes
that have been happening that's a lie
it's a complete freaking lie like i
actually want to show you this because
it is
it is a devastation it's
awful
look at it
it's terrible
i am embarrassed of what a pig i've
become and it's not really it's not
really my fault i mean it's kind of my
fault i have been traveling so much this
month it is completely overwhelming and
i mean i can't complain because i
absolutely do love to travel but a lot
of unexpected things came up i don't
like to talk about too personal of
things uh sometimes basically it's just
been roller coaster of emotions
month i went from austin texas directly
to san francisco back here for a day and
then went on vacation to hawaii for my
birthday which was really fun but then i
had to take an unexpected trip home to
pittsburgh
and then directly back from pittsburgh i
flew back to los angeles for the call of
duty championships and went right to
rehearsals and that's what's going on
right now this weekend and it's been
really really fun so depending upon when
you're watching this you guys can tune
into xbox to watch the finals on sunday
i don't know when you're watching this
you could be watching it next week you
could be watching this three years from
now
you guys started tweeting me that's when
i knew i had to post a video where'd you
go uh i love you guys should we make
sure that you guys know that i posted
one of the why videos yesterday and a
lot of you guys were like wait justine
aren't you in los angeles aren't you
hosting the call of duty championship
right now yes i am i just got home from
there i think i'm losing my voice but i
had so much energy from just being
excited all day and watching call of
duty that i
am actually gonna play for about an hour
before i go to bed i apologize that my
add is all over the place you guys
probably haven't followed
anything that i've said have i formed a
complete sentence yet
i don't even know let's just hope for no
more earthquakes because it's freaking
scary i think there's an earthquake
filter so if there is i'm gonna apply
the earthquake filter here and this is
what it's like
but in real life so to go along with
this crazy month i'm so upset because my
favorite classes broke and i was like i
don't know
i don't know what to do
and somebody tweeted me about warby
parker you can basically well i have
them in front of me you can choose five
glasses they ship you some example
frames that you could try on and then
you choose the ones you like and now i
need you guys to help me pick
which glasses
i should order oh
oh
oh shoot i just i i just leaned on this
bear
you have to send these back after you
try them on and decide which ones you
want i think i actually like these
that's number one two
i don't want to make any facial
expressions because i don't want to sway
your opinion of what i think this is
number three
no facial expressions stop making facial
expressions justine
i want you to have an unbiased opinion
they have so many to pick from it took
me five hours to choose these five one
hour per
glasses actually the first time i'm
seeing them all okay so here we go
this was one
two
this would have been three this is five
this is four please help me
i'm indecisive
i'm physically exhausted and jet lagged
and i need a new pair of glasses
asap my other ones were kind of all this
same shape if you remember um
so what do we do what do we do here
is the question
the best part about it is i was so
excited i actually tweeted them and they
gave me a
code if you guys want to get them
they'll give you free expedited shipping
if you decide to actually get a pair so
hopefully i'm going to be using my own
ijustine code to hopefully get a new
pair of glasses
in two days
before i leave for another trip speaking
of which i'm so excited guys i'm going
somewhere next week i can't wait to take
you with me and i'm hoping that i can do
a meet-up in this place that i'm going
it's far away it's a place that i never
thought that i would ever go
if you guys want to take a guess as to
where you think it may be
uh leave a comment but also please leave
a comment on which glasses i should get
because i'd like to have them before i
leave for this destination
oh my god i want them all is that
possible
all right
there was also an update video that i
told you i was gonna make i still
haven't edited it edited it i did shoot
it it was
the conversation that i was having with
myself and with you about whether i
should merge my channels because i
actually sometimes spend more time
editing my other ijustine vlogs than i
do on my main channel videos this
channel is supposed to be for like
secondary content and sometimes these
vlogs end up being better than my main
channel videos so i was thinking i'd
like to move those vlogs to my main
channel i don't know i'm too tired
to really function at this point in the
night i don't know i don't know where am
i right now
is this my house
do i live here
i got this
shirt
it's south by southwest
it is
a sub
filled shirt like is this not beautiful
or what
i don't know what i said in this video
i'll have some more of the hawaii
adventures for you guys coming up this
week well i gotta go to bed because i
have to get up at four o'clock tomorrow
morning again for more call of duty fun
i love you guys i'm super excited about
getting a new pair of glasses oh and
another thing which is absolutely just
the coolest thing ever
is when you guys buy a pair of glasses
from warby parker they actually donate a
pair of glasses to a person in need and
those are the kind of companies that i
love to work with and that i love to
support because there's nothing like
helping someone that needs help so props
to you guys that's awesome what a great
concept let me know if you guys end up
getting a pair let me know which ones
you guys get let me know which ones i
should get so i can
go on this fun
trip and hopefully see some of you guys
in this destination that you will know
of
very soon did i make any sense in this
video
no
okay
well see you later
oh my god my house is a disaster